hey glad to be with you we'll continue
our series of lateral cutter Bible
stories in a second uh just wanted to uh
kind of issue this call to action here
do you know anyone out there who is in
need this Christmas we're going to be
doing a big Christmas special uh
December 15th if you watch last year's
we'll have a link in the description uh
we just did a basically a whole two
hours uh with Santa Santa Claus I guess
Crowder close I don't know Santa Claus
uh and helped out families in need and
and did some stuff with with children it
was a lot of fun honestly one of the
most fun shows that I've ever done uh
this year we'll be delivering Christmas
baskets uh or we'll be delivering checks
whatever people need so if you can email
me at Crowder Christmas crowder.com uh
someone who you think could really use
this or maybe it's yourself please send
your email at Crowder christmas.com
we're looking forward to doing that
December 15th and giving back also uh
something you know a few people haven't
done it yet if you come out to a live
show there's something really special
especially around this season in being
surrounded by like-minded people knowing
that you're not alone New Jersey is sold
out this weekend but there are still
tickets in Baltimore I think yeah
December 3rd this Saturday and keep in
mind there's always about two percent of
tickets that release the day of people
couldn't find a sitter or you know
people weren't able to make it so if you
walk up find out when the ticket counter
opens up uh you might be able to snag
yourself one day of but get there early
on with the show Bible stories
foreign
I just don't understand why you won't
tell me what would make you as weak as
any other man what what I repeat what is
that it of course why why would I tell
you that oh you don't trust me is that
it is that a serious question is that a
serious question of course I don't
know the last time we went out for drink
Tuesday at happy hour you said hey what
would make you this week is it you
remember what would make you as weak as
any other man I said I don't know I
don't know we had a couple of Daiquiris
oh you know what if I wake up tied in
fresh ropes lo and behold the very next
morning
fresh ropes they still smell like new
robes that was a sex thing Samson oh it
was a sex thing was it was it was it a
sex thing because I don't remember any
sex
as part of that thing but while we're on
the subject the next time what would
make you as weak as any other man why
don't you trust me and I tell you you
know if someone were to tie my hair in a
weave I would lose all my power and I
wake up like this
I love the new look who would love this
new book who am I Boy George no one
likes this look listen I just need you
to trust me oh you need me to trust you
okay now we're at the point where we
talk about your needs forget about my
needs and all the strongest man in the
world who's who's actually tasked with
ensuring the bloodline of the large
people effectively do you have any do
you have an idea how hard it is to kill
over a dozen people with the Jawbone of
a donkey no no do you know how hard it
is to actually get a Jawbone off a
donkey isn't gonna work if you don't
trust me
okay
boxed boundaries No Boundaries we need
to work on this together we're a team
we are not each other's enemy
my hair okay that's the source of all my
power you want me to trust you there it
is I'm being vulnerable instead of angry
because anger is not an emotion it
simply masks the real emotion we know
that
my hair were cut
I'd be as weak as any of them
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that was a lot hotter than I expected
not a little bit a lot I'm talking Sue
McDonald's coffee hot
by the way if you don't know about that
case I believe me I'm against frivolous
lawsuits you if you think oh she sued
McDonald's for hot coffee no no dude it
was it was rough I'm burning it it was a
real it's a real
Freddy kuchker oh come on now yeah so uh
we have a lot to get to today if some of
this is uh if some of it seems remedial
there is some relevancy to Elizabeth
Warren wanting to control all of the
flow of information as she's speaking
out against Elon Musk we also know a
little bit more about what's going on
between Elon Musk and apple and we know
what's been happening with Twitter
before Elon Musk as it relates to
election meddling not everything but
again this is the war of our time this
is the most important Battle of your
time is the Battle of information and
something I really have wanted to talk
about for a while but I needed to lay
out a case all references are available
at letterscredit.com and that's my
question today do you believe that the
middle class is shrinking if you are gen
Z if you're a younger Millennial do you
feel as though or do you think I should
say let's eliminate feel from the
Lexicon do you think that it is harder
for you to achieve the American dream
than your parents who are likely in the
uh you know baby boomer generation
there's some truth to it and I think
that conservatives Republicans would do
well to hear it but it's not the truth
that you think it is and the solution is
freedom and more options because there's
also a silver lining where you can live
much much more luxuriously than your
parents if you make decisions the
problem is the decisions that you have
to make fly in the face of every
decision that you are told to make from
kindergarten all the way through
University so we're talking about that
also women's soccer equality yay they're
getting paid as much as the uh the man
ish
boo
is that Gerald a how are you I'm doing
well how are you doing I'm good but two
men adjusting my headphones now it
sounds like I'm in a pool are these new
headphones oh they look nice are they
new headphones oh no now it's all
muffled I don't give a sh
it I don't like I have a big head we
don't have headphone kind of money here
I have famous guy head and I'm not that
famous
[Laughter]
you do have movie star head that's not
bad though but you know his movie star
head is Josh Brolin he's like a walking
bobble head well he has Easter Island
heads yes he does his head was
constructed by ancient Druids yes
oh you know him you love him of course
we are in Baltimore December 3rd uh you
can go and get your tickets there it's
our last show of the Year together
Rebels with the cause tour Dave Landau
how are you Ahoy good how about you man
good you're wearing invest so really you
only get cold but it's because I wanted
to I wanted to show off one of the
shirts in the merch shop so your arms
don't get cold correct okay now I'm
gonna button it
oh good it doesn't oh you suffer from
you suffer from cold sternum as well
yeah mine is mainly because it's
titanium I do my my arms run hot today
we all have our cross to bear mine is a
titanium cross in my chest oh no I
didn't realize this is the first time
where it's been really cold it gets cold
I can feel the cold bars oh I remember
last year when I kept falling and
cracking my head on the ice outside of
my oh that's true yeah it did happen but
uh yeah I was insulated okay so before
we move on uh with the rest of the news
and again this is what's happening with
what's been going on with big Tech with
Twitter this is a big deal it's one
billionaire one 4chan artist which is
fantastic versus all of the other
wealthy Elite and you are seeing this
Coalition you're seeing them all
coalesce right now saying oh we're gonna
start losing some power so you are now
seeing everyone's True Colors so yes
this subject matter is important to
cover and if it seems repetitive to some
people there's always a new development
because there's always new information
that is made available Elizabeth Warren
she just can't catch a break poor girl
that's what happens every time you speak
if it's a lie well yeah yeah which is a
politician so we just assume that but
she's also yeah she's also white yeah no
wait no not Native American zero Parts
it's my cookbook incorrect yes yeah
didn't you think it was weird that the
Sioux were cooking enchiladas Oh I
thought it was strange
it says these Salisbury Iroquois steak
Yeah
is
which by the way they had to substitute
the buffalo meat because they hunted
them to Extinction not true see with all
the colors of the forest so a Vancouver
woman uh has now approached parental
rights activists I believe this is in
Canada because it's Vancouver
to confront the people who are
confronting the drag queen activists who
are sexualizing their children but this
woman doesn't have a problem with it and
she makes Salient points yeah how is a
human being dressing how they want to
dress sexualizing anything it's a human
body
sure
it's a body it
takes we have naked men reading to
little kids sure it's a human body okay
okay so look I don't entirely disagree
with the point even though she's gross
the last point we all disagree with yeah
what should we have naked men reading to
children and she says yes
hold on a second it depends you're
talking like bath time like in shorts
it's not fully naked no no I think she
mentioned a lot yes no I know you're
correct yeah it'll be a lot of shushing
if I was inside the Library it would be
yes but here's the thing I agree look
context over content I don't think
there's a problem with nudity this is
the this is the issue right if you're a
conservative you can make sure that you
counterbalance this effectively for
example right David God uh when you're
talking about these a bunch of beautiful
art Michael oh is it David meets God
what's the name of the uh the creation
of man or the creation of man with the
fingers touching and the ultra small
penises
I think that was someone who had a
girlfriend who's like no see they all
look like that yeah
even even God even the man after God's
Own Heart because of penis that size
it's still harder than yours
yes was it an Asian model but the point
is it's the creation of Adam the
creation of Adam sorry I got that wrong
you can admonish me later but there's
nothing wrong I would have nothing uh
nothing against my children seeing that
nudity in itself is not something that
is inherently uh immoral right we are
all born naked now the issue is when you
have uh degenerate men dressed as women
twerking their ball sack and children's
face next to the pop-out book section
that's the context with which we have a
problem I believe yeah well and it was
this guy I think was saying okay look I
get you say it's just a human body and
you can wear whatever you want to wear
he didn't go like okay so lingerie okay
like edible panties or anything like
that he's like I'm gonna go as far as I
can possibly go because of course she's
gonna say no to this how about a naked
guy reading to children and she's like
yeah why not he's like
is that a serious question do you need
me to answer
well yeah it's unbelievable that she
answered yes well I think she just yeah
she's a garbage I think it's entirely
believable though that's the problem
it's entirely believable this is where
this is what again the question you have
to ask yourself is not what is the left
doing right now what are Democrats doing
right now what would they do if there
were no checks and balances if they had
complete unfettered access to power this
lady would have naked strange men
reading to your children hey hold on a
second that's not a straw man argument
remember they would say this we're like
well what's next naked men reading to
your kids Once Upon a Time the left
would have said oh don't do that don't
straw man us then she said yeah what's
the problem what do you have a problem
with balls in children's face I do call
me old-fashioned
yeah right after she said that it should
just say Kindle just down
there's no taint I'm still I'm still
hoping that my Nook becomes relevant yes
I'm just trying to think of what I can
say
I put on I put on the softies the Ranger
panties that we have at uh
crowdershop.com when I do bath time with
the little ones well that's because
you're their dad yeah but I'm saying I
put those on still because like you know
in other words I get the some dads
sometimes like they go naked with like
babies bath time whatever the point is I
understand the context this is not that
and do you guys find yourself hey this
is a question that do you find yourself
uh making up songs when you're like with
your little kids that you're kind of
ashamed of like Dad jokes songs of
course of course to my son would be a
little red Wyatt
much too fast why is he driving he's
seven I know but that's why because he's
got a power wheel oh okay yeah that's
right I do please don't cry you have to
go to sleep you know something like that
it's time to scrub a dub scrub all the
mud won't get no mud on me
that's so much worse than I swear to you
I put them because I have whole routine
so I can vary about one of those towel
down okay and then you know you
obviously you put on like the uh sarave
or Aquaphor yeah I like clean butts and
I cannot lie I'm sure I've done that
I've done it with thousands of songs so
I'll even do it with like my dogs I'll
be like yeah I love it when you come a
big puppy
it's just stupid but I think everybody
kind of does it do yeah let us know
comment below if you're a dad if you're
a mom if you do this and if you also
like us feel great shame you won't see
it on stage in December no no no no
you're Delirious yes oh wait a second uh
before we uh there's some breaking news
oh
foreign
[Music]
oh man uh well it looks like hold on a
second it looks like a Bill Clinton uh
was just diagnosed he has covid but you
should know before he feels fantastic
looks great
oh good oh Jesus he's doing fine wow is
that post here
[Music]
that wasn't a costume
murdered a guy oh boy yeah it looks like
she got him now
well Casey did it while you were taking
us
wow we did a whole segment on that go
and watch our Norm episode he was kicked
off of The View for about half a decade
that was hilarious yeah you know it's
gonna get to murders out of the White
House you know why oh yeah Bill Clinton
19
I look how they called back to it like
seconds later she says well come on
you're supposed to be funny he's like
hey how did you not know that yeah you
can't do that you're supposed to behave
okay and he goes out he goes yeah and uh
you know like he killed the guy
and then later the funniest thing he
ever said is a star Jones is on it he
goes yeah I didn't really like Star Wars
though that much but you know something
like a billy uh you know like Billy D
Williams you know what I'm talking about
yeah
all right we're gonna go on sale this is
with Lauren and Elon Musk that was the I
think the first celebrity when he died I
did I cried by myself oh yeah it was so
sad for me Let It Go yeah it really is I
would say so so Elizabeth Warren Elon
Musk this is another Turf War
I should say this sorry um it's more of
a uh it's an invasion of Elizabeth
Warren's land that she wants back
weird one one thousand sixteenth of her
so um and you hit the like button hit
share by the way if you're watching
right now because the algorithms say
that we're dead we're going to be
discussing some things here that uh
YouTube doesn't want us discussing and
if they ban us fine you can follow us on
Rumble you can watch on Rumble head on
over there it's a live show Monday
through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern by that
I mean 10 15. but 10 a.m Eastern and uh
head on over to rumble I would love to
see the numbers go switch over uh okay
Elizabeth Warren you've been following
us mm-hmm levelism uh yes can't get
enough of her I I only follow her dreams
when I see her naked in the desert yes
it's the doors nightmare yes
our chamber's just a boiler room
so Elizabeth Warren uh was asked by a
reporter uh and then she responded and
this is what's concerning about this
when you hear Elizabeth Warren and when
you hear uh whoever it is insert today
whether it's AOC insert whichever
Democrat politician member of the DNC
starts speaking out when you hear them
speak out against Elon Musk I just want
you to picture the voice of their
friends Mark Zuckerberg Jeff Bezos Susan
wojcicki because we know they have
meetings and we know that they've worked
alongside them so Elizabeth Warren was
asked about Elon Musk with that context
here's how she answered Republicans say
that Democrats are picking on Elon Musk
Elon Musk is doing just fine but do you
think that users have a right to freedom
of speech even if what they're saying is
wrong or offensive I think that one
human being should not decide how
millions of people communicate with each
other one human being should not be able
to go into a dark room by himself and
decide oh that person gets hurt from
that person doesn't that's not how it
should work I completely agree
interesting completely agree why does
the room have to be dark there's a
little bit of projection there she has a
lot of lights offset yes
solo yes well yeah because her husband's
not interested there no man should be in
the dark and be able to determine who
gets to speak and who doesn't by asking
their mirror mirror on the wall
that wasn't the question I didn't hear
you you're right
it's part of my people's Traditions do
you see the problem here you can comment
below so look you have Elizabeth Warren
let's go through this uh she's long been
by the way proponent of antitrust laws
right and breaking up big Tech that
sounds good that sounds good on the
surface on the surface right different
thing when you're talking about Free
Speech section 230 versus antitrust but
it's a component to it so here you have
from her website references available at
lotto.com we must hold these big tech
companies accountable and break them up
though okay go read the rest of it then
it's just a bunch of fluff because
you're not actually seeing what that
means it's okay you're saying this how
how and the why matters and you can't
consistently line up on the wrong side
accidentally always you never have an
accident that airs on the side of
freedom let's look at what she actually
wants to do here Elizabeth Warren wants
to control the flow of information
herself so during her 2020 presidential
campaign she vowed to quote push to
create civil and criminal penalties for
knowingly disseminating false
information about when and how to vote
in U.S elections and prior to the 2020
election this is what she wrote on her
website I have already called out
Facebook for permitting political
candidates to run plainly false ads on
it on its platform by the way also
included false stories 100bine laptop
remember they all said it was Russian
disinformation that's why it was banned
from all these social media platforms
the entire DNC establishment said that's
Russian propaganda hold on a second do
you think they didn't vet it or do you
think they wanted you to believe that it
was Russian propaganda which by the way
directly affected the outcome of the
election so she wants to have a direct
line and she says that she has a direct
line to call for misinformation and
they've been wrong on misinformation
we've been banned for misinformation
That Was Then on misinformationed on
YouTube to be clear yeah well we and we
knew it at the time it wasn't like new
information came to light that all of a
sudden made us right it was readily
available no the CDC statistics changed
but I mean the 2016 statistics they
changed in 2022 yeah right yeah right
she also wrote the safety of our
democracy is more important than
shareholders dividends and CEO salaries
and we need tech companies to behave
accordingly that's why I'm calling on
them to take real steps right now to
fight so she just said they shouldn't be
able to run these political campaign ads
for example you know that you had people
on the right saying hey the left did
this Russia collusion hoax right I think
that was one of Ted Cruz's uh ads I
don't remember exactly but this was
obviously a central point in Republican
ads they want to say that's mitz
information even though we know
verifiably that it's true so she wants
to silence political opponents that's
fine if she doesn't want anyone to run
political ads
has Elizabeth Warren trick it's not a
trick question one Facebook ad just uh
that ran between October 26th November
30th spent thirty five thousand dollars
oh so she's fine with it first so yes
when she can benefit that is she's
saying I want to be able to run Facebook
ads and but the thing is I don't I don't
engage in misinformation just take her
word for it don't don't bother peering
behind the curtain and seeing that she
of course was on the Russia Russia
Russia train here you go Elizabeth
Warren disinformation was one of the
several potent strategies that the
Russian government employed to influence
the 2016 election wait I thought all
elections were safe there secure that
there was no way that we could question
the outcome of what happened no no yeah
no no no no no no well I think Chief
runs from reporter is quite a hypocrite
yes
paints with all the colors of the
[ __ ]
think about that she's saying oh Russia
2016. they always wanted that election
to be in doubt and then they continued
with that to try and affect the election
in 2020 by having one of the most
important stories that involved the
current political candidate former Vice
President Joe Biden's corruption with
his son the hunter Biden laptop that was
Russian disinformation Elizabeth Warren
AOC uh uh kinzinger they all supported
getting that off of social media do you
see the problem with them determining
what is misinformation I agree it
shouldn't only be Elon right but Elon is
elon's allowing people on he's not
getting rid of people do you see the
difference yes his mistake is basically
saying I'm going to let everybody have a
platform in a way to communicate what
she wants is for a room of people to get
together and say what is and isn't
allowed arbitrarily not based on fact
and then it's okay if one person decides
like Mark Zuckerberg or the former
Twitter guy in Chief right before he
left that's the people that she wants to
be able to do it under marching orders
if they're going out there and saying
you can have a platform and you can
speak freely she's not okay with that
right why would that be the case in the
United States today why is that even
part of the conversation well here's the
truth is they want and people like
Elizabeth Warren they want Twitter uh to
be treated differently than all of it
here's the thing they want all of the
big Tech platforms to continue as is
they're happy with them right are you
happy with them they want to change
Twitter because Elon can't be controlled
he's one of the few people remember when
people used to say I don't think that we
should have billionaires running for
office so you want screw-ups to run the
country there is some value in being
someone who is autonomous not being
capable of being bought and sold and I
understand that it's not only financial
sometimes people are just they're just
grasping for power I get it but they
want to treat all the other social
platforms one way and Twitter
differently there's only one platform
that is allowing more both right wing
and left-wing opinions on the platform
today one it's the one that they want to
censor for not censoring enough just
listen to National Security
communications director John Kirby
explain it again I think we've been very
clear and consistent on this uh
certainly publicly we you've been very
open about our desires to be able to see
citizens communicate and then you know
Apple if this is a decision that they're
making then they should have to speak to
that but uh we you know we're not we
can't and we aren't in the business of
of telling private companies how to to
execute the their their initiative but
Twitter's a private company too so why
is Twitter getting one treatment and
Apple's getting another is my question
well those are completely two different
circumstances but are they oh are they
really are there I mean the White House
comes out and says we're going to keep
an eye on Twitter because they're
practicing free speech and you guys well
we're going to have to keep an eye on
Apple blocks not related to these
protests it's actually worse just
because some guys held up a sign that
says XI xingping should be removed from
office a month ago and you guys are like
I mean Apple they're a private company I
know that's how people communicate
Elizabeth Warren one guy shouldn't be
able to go into a room and determine how
millions of people what about a billion
what about over a billion people
communicating in China via the airdrop
app to make sure that they can protest
and communicate with one another well
wasn't it also interesting how much more
toxic Twitter was from the left ran I
know actually must kind of sweet about
that I know I was when that was
happening I was one of the the primary
targets of actual
actually yeah
and then paint me as a Nazi they started
you know photoshopping swastikas and
quotes about gassing Jews and I was like
I didn't and I went to Twitter said hey
you know this is actually like
defamatory it's attributing a quote to
me that I didn't make and I don't have
that tattoo I shouldn't have sent them a
nude pic for verification but at that
point and they said there's nothing we
can do we allow this but then they would
remove a post that included the CDC
stats right well they said sir the
picture in question was not of your
penis why did you send us a picture I
said no that is my penis yes just zoom
out I sent Michelangelo's penis yeah it
was a very large m m see I told you they
all look like this see all that size and
they're all gray you sent them a side by
side
but think about this is something people
also miss Facebook okay so you have
let's look at the big social platforms
you have Facebook right Facebook and
Instagram then you have YouTube That's
alphabet that's YouTube that's Google
okay it's not really social media but
you understand the point Twitter is a
distant third that's the only reason
Elon was able to purchase it the way
that he did it's a distant if you're
talking about influence it's not even
close to Facebook why are they spending
so much time on Twitter which is nowhere
near the size nowhere near the user base
well the cardinal sin that Elon Musk has
committed is allowing conservatives on
the platform allowing the then sitting
president when he was removed back on
the platform just because ah we're gonna
allow the Ayatollah and members of Isis
I think he deserves to have a say
think about how much power you think you
have to where you're like I'm gonna get
rid of the president yes like you're
just and all half the people are just
sitting there on you know the Starbucks
Lounge that oddly enough a billionaire
didn't consider work right uh but just
going on there and trying to find
anything that they disagree with calling
it misinformation blocking accounts yeah
for years we're finding out this
happened absolutely now imagine being
the [ __ ] who bought that right oh
that's it must have good enough for me
if Elizabeth Warren says it it must be
true right oh hold on oh okay AOC Center
OH Joe Biden said it saki said it said
it good enough for me yep okay well then
if their word is was Elon musk's word
who doesn't have a dog in the fight
politically aside from allowing all
voices to speak why don't you give him
the same Credence I am not asking I I
would be furious if you want sort of
just removing leftists for no reason
just to be clear if that starts
happening I will speak out against it
come back here hold me to my word also
hit the like button right now if you're
watching on YouTube because they do not
want you to see what's coming up
and here's the problem too you know the
Streisand Effect that people talk about
uh just have a word of advice Democrats
be careful when you engage in this
because because when you start
de-platforming people it actually can
end up going wrong and be it can become
more of a problem just for more look
what happened after Chase created this
Leviathan of competition when they
de-platformed Kanye from their Bank
yeah the easy Bank cash card gets you
more money back for your purchases than
all competitors we go in Defcon 3 on all
them Zionist cars huh whoa whoa that's
that sounds good but as a possible new
customer I have to say that last part
seemed a little anti-semitic yo I can't
be anti-semitic because I'm the real
skeptic better yet I'm the antiseptic
I'm the real peptide yeah we don't steal
your money or control the media or sleep
in bed with your ex-wife looking at her
with your big butt hole eyes okay look
that last one doesn't even sound like
it's about Jewish people I think maybe
you need to take your medication I don't
need no medication I just need some
consternation seems to me you don't
learn a lot from Satan but I Praise
Jesus y'all better Praise Jesus that's
me without me this even rhesus can't go
with pieces huh praise be to me most
high ye
passing it I ain't going with him are
you robbing the bank oh no I'm here to
take Kanye back to Zombieland he needs
to take his medicine just like you said
not like this I need to call the police
don't reach for your phone you shot me
in the hand I'm bleeding everywhere you
leaking in My Adidas I'm sorry Yeezys
come on yay okay but don't forget to use
Yeezy Bank don't worry we got you
it's clever slogan it's a good
commercial
it's not a commercial so much that we
procured that from the NSA they're
responding oh I didn't think the
customer service line would actually be
Yeezus well you gotta start somewhere I
thought they just said that I thought it
was more of an umbrella term I found it
an appealing ad me too
foreign
[Laughter]
it must be damn but can't say who Damn
is
because I get a free pass is what media
huh Jewels okay oh
all right Kanye you can put Converse on
there you can put Nike on there but no
Adidas it's controlled by all the udans
talk to me I'd rather go with Putin ah
stop with the thing so Elon Musk
hey if you guys are mad about that
because there's no sense of humor like
you're like yeah I just support yeah
name me name me the uh the best tracks
name of the singles from College Dropout
go
which is his first and in my opinion
best album one of those I do think the
dark and Twisted Fantasy is underrated
it's a good album it is a good album I
do like his first though no no it's
fantastic I used to get complaints when
this was on AM radio because I used one
of his songs as a bump like you
shouldn't use that because here Taylor
Swift like he makes good music and he's
also uh crazy so Elon Musk he took an
award for many children that's not your
award yeah I don't care puppy I'm gonna
let you finish but Beyonce had the best
video of all time yeah here's your War
back good luck I remember that happened
this is Thursday so just let you know
we're gonna get to some importance but
how amazingly rude that was why not
remember uh balloon boy remember that
when people thought there was a kid in a
balloon it turned out it was fraudulent
everyone was watching without this kid
is going to crash I saw someone this was
back before meme culture is really big
it must have been 2009 and someone had
Kanye pop it and wrote us give them and
he said yo yo balloon boy I'm gonna let
you finish but Amelia Earhart had the
best disappearance of all time
I made scenes and I remember I was
peeing myself like okay
if that gets removed from YouTube like I
said it's a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern you can head on
over to rumble of course we'll be doing
some more segments on mug club today
it's chat Thursday ah you never know
what's gonna what's gonna trigger the
band here but we're not going to change
what we do so there we go as for me in
my house we will uh you know piss off
the right people Elon Musk his rivalry
with Tim Cook uh it seems like it's done
here we talked about this yesterday and
we talked about it yesterday I did say
there's some things that we can't
confirm there are some things that we
can confirm we were able to confirm that
uh Apple had been pulling some
advertising but we weren't able to
confirm that Tim pool threatened to pull
to Twitter Tim poll doesn't have that
kind of power temple that men did a hit
job huh
he asked me a question in an interview
actually no I asked him a question when
he tried to answer I said don't answer
me because I'm ye and then I left
he asked him Paul a question yeah and
Timber was like well I don't I don't uh
use the term they as I believe you do
that's it this is far too reasonable
what was crazy was it was just such an
inappropriate time to leave you just
like all of a sudden was walking behind
us and you're like I don't know you see
Tim Paul like doing this like he's crazy
enough he might hit me yeah yeah I don't
yeah yeah you better Bob and weave [ __ ]
Temple half asian you my sensation I'm
about to give you some condemnation yeah
stop
stop
just happens so it does seem that the
two meaning Elon Musk and Tim Cook thank
you uh had a meeting yesterday and so
that brings us to this segment no Gerald
knows things
[Music]
I don't know that I like any of you guys
well it's okay all right so we talked
about it potentially removing Twitter
from the App Store that was the big
thing we talked about how much
information they control well they
actually uh met and Elon tweeted out
actually that they had a good
conversation among other things we
resolved the misunderstanding I'll get
back to that about Twitter potentially
being removed from the App Store Tim was
clear that Apple never considered doing
so I'm not a hundred percent sure that I
believe any of that now I do believe
that they aren't going to remove them
from the App Store sure I don't think
that Tim Cook couldn't have sent a tweet
basically saying not true or maybe a
direct message or picked up the phone
and said this I don't think it took a
sit down to come to oh yeah that was
never actually going to happen could
have mirror linked it I feel well it
could have that's a pretty impressive
little invention they've got going there
I think what happened is Tim Cook and
this is just me yes I think he backed
down yes I think I think Elon Musk does
pose a threat to Apple that Apple would
do very well to avoid he could launch
his own phone if he wanted to he could
do pretty much anything in Tech that he
wants to do and do it very well and
compete with people and take market
share this is exactly why you cannot
negotiate for peace from a position of
weakness that's not possible he also
sent this uh interesting if not
breathtaking video from Apple HQ oh
the Tweet is thanks for taking me around
Apple's beautiful HQ where are the
Chinese kids being Bull with yes you
showed a pool
that was filled with leaves but it
wasn't even clean you don't have to you
can't afford a skimmer yeah nobody can
go in the pool what is this so basically
I don't think he could really ever be
serious about taking them off I mean
that's a big big app you don't want to
do that to a customer like that right
they're making a lot of money off of it
and the plan of Twitter was removed is
is kind of tweeted out here too I
certainly hope it does not come to that
but yes if there is no other choice I
will make an alternative phone like I
said he could do that he could make that
happen yes Elon Musk could do it and I
think that that's one of the reasons
that they back down so we'll see if that
is actually the case and here's my
question too unfor look I'm not a
billionaire okay in case you couldn't
guess
um
where are all the conservative billion
why is Elon Musk carrying your water for
you yeah why is he doing this hey you
don't you mean to tell me there's no one
on the right who has enough money where
they could have stepped down
Tim I would not say Tim Apple Tim Apple
that's the best one though Tim Fuji he's
a Courtland call me tackle give me
Snapple you mean that none of them could
have stepped him down they're all
creating other platforms and then
selling them to other people and
charging service fees we're the
conservatives with the money the people
who say this is their reason they're
charging the hill why is it Elon who has
been a lifelong Democrat who now is fed
up with it that is a story that I think
we're missing here because we've had
politicians on the show we've called
them to the map where we've said look
subpoena demand that I go to a hearing
they don't they don't want to well you
know that we have some information that
nobody else has with these big Tech
platforms please call us and they're
like yeah no no it's about the clip it's
about the clip that we get online elon's
not looking for a clip Elon is actually
unloading and I know it's not a clip
it's a magazine and I mean figuratively
on the people who are trying to silence
any voices of descent he is going after
the Kings and the King makers where are
all the conservatives with the power and
the money you can't negotiate from a
position of weakness Elon understands
that we know that he people on the right
understand that but they're not doing
anything and we are funded by viewers
like you we of course fight back as best
we can but we know I mean the best we
can do is tank Google's stock price like
after the Vox apocalypse that was fun
but it was accidental they came back but
so one of the things I want to say is he
has so much at risk like he's got
billions of his own dollars obviously
but he's also got several companies he's
got his reputation his ability to do
anything if you know anything about Elon
Musk it's not about the dollars for him
he wants to change the world that's been
his thing the entire time he wants to
change how people interact with her
being Commerce whether it be in speech
whether it be in cars whether it be
going to Mars whether it be neuralink to
try to help people he wants to change
the world that's his thing he's putting
all of that on the line to make sure
that your free speech is protected so
you have to respect that one thing he
also did he dropped some information in
a tweet the other day that's right
basically gave us a little bit of a peek
behind the curtain into something that
we thought was it's not as enough
information yet but it is interesting
yeah so hopefully we'll get some details
to this yeah here's the quote from him
the obvious reality is long time users
know is that Twitter has failed and
trust and safety for a very long time
and has interfered in elections
Elon Musk just said that Twitter has
interfered based on what he has seen I
think there's just something else
important though what he said and keep
in mind too even if you just believe
that these are these people are are
being manipulated by purse strings okay
if you believe that oh they're only
being subject to Market forces there's
some truth to that
it's why by the way for example I have a
lot of uh hope for a company like Rumble
I understand that they're public
companies and people say well what uh
what happens in the shareholders demand
that they start censoring content well
here's the thing if Rumble decides to
start censoring content they're of no
value to their shareholders because they
said screw you to the entire government
of France and they're the alternative to
YouTube so it sort of is a beautiful
safety check right it's well hold on a
second they're only as valuable as the
freedom that they provide for Content
creators who want to leave the ghettos
of YouTube that's a very good thing and
of course there are people who work at
Rumble who we also know truly do believe
in the cause and they've been
transparent and helpful could have had
the servers a little more robust on
Election night but you know what hey I
get it we're all in a learning curve
they're growing they're growing yeah but
this is what he tweeted out Elon Musk he
said Twitter 2.0 will be far more
effective transparent and even-handed oh
the horror so in other words Twitter is
only valuable if the user base that's
their Capital whole Elon Musk
accountable to his right there mission
statement his mission statement is
Twitter 2.0 will be now this is hey how
am I going to effectively create value
will be more effective transparent and
even-handed let's contrast that with
Elizabeth Warren with AOC with Mark
Zuckerberg saying we need to do more to
stop the spread of hate in other words
that's their business model where now
they are beholden to a user base who
says yeah yeah we want you to we want
you to work with the government and get
rid of misinformation the people who are
going to be using Twitter the only
reason that they're going to Twitter now
it is clear as day is because Elon Musk
has promised that it will be more
effective transparent even-handed look
we can disagree do you want more control
do you want more clamping down on
misinformation like getting rid of the
hunter Biden laptop story do you want to
get rid of hate meaning people who say
that hey maybe we shouldn't have mass
mail-in voting or do you line up with
the mission statement from Elon Musk
effective transparent even-handed
approach that's a question that I have
that only you can answer this really
does come down to your own personal
opinion what do you expect to see and
which one do you line up with yeah um
and they can comment there below yeah
yeah so what I hope to see though too is
that he releases the information that
he's talked about releasing too he has
said in the past that he is going to
release information about the back
behind the scenes Communications between
the White House and Twitter and
everybody else so what do you expect I
guess is is what I want to know like the
viewer Steven you guys like do you do
you expect it to be this like I want to
hear Dave first because I have some
information that you can tell me when to
shut up okay no with the half asian
lawyer bill so Dave you go first no I
just agree like if he's got all the
access to everything that's happened now
that he owns the company and he's saying
election tampering and everything else
obviously he has some Intel yeah I would
like to see it hey you know what Elon
and Gerald you can tell me when I have
to shut up don't tell me to shut up you
can look into our account because we did
file motions do we have a lawsuit we
don't have a current loss are we suing
them they're suing us it's tough to keep
track but I do know that we filed some
motions and we won so check doors look
into what happened with me so here's
what happened this is a story that
actually happened with Twitter just so
you can understand some context and by
the way I would say this under oath so
consider this consider this right a
penalty of perjury if I'm lying so Elon
okay go look into what happened with my
account here's what happened Twitter
reached out to me and said hey you can
reach more users if you uh advertise to
people I said oh okay at this point I
wasn't really running a lot of
advertising but the business was growing
I believe this might have been around
2011. I said how do I do that they said
well what do you want do you want your
tweets to get more interactions or do
you want to gain more followers and I
said well you know what at the time I
was on Fox News and a lot of people
weren't online they would see me on Fox
news but they wouldn't give me the plugs
right so I said you know I'd like to
kind of you know Target people who might
see me on television and you give them
the opportunity to follow me they said
oh so you want a targeted campaign to
find followers they came to me I said
okay how do I do that they said well you
can just write out a few tweets so
something and they wrote out these
tweets themselves
Twitter ads to be clear approached me
and wrote the ads themselves I didn't do
it
and they said yeah you know things like
uh it would create a set of three or
four or five tweets and what will happen
is it'll show up in someone's timeline
when you pay and it'll offer these
people to follow you it'll say promote
an account I said okay one of them was
hate progressives follow me to quell thy
pain as seen on your Fox News right okay
later on either suspended me or removed
my Twitter analytics saying that that
was a violation of hate speech I'm like
wait wait you took money for that and
you wrote it
you cashed the check yes and so what
ended up happening they said okay well
we'll unsuspend you but you know what
you just can't run ads anymore I'm like
you mean I can't I can't run the ads you
wrote you you asked me to run ads I
don't understand that as Crowder Elon
Musk go look into the advertisement
history yes you can question me call me
to the mat that happened and you know
what the truth is like yeah it would
obviously make a difference for everyone
if you don't have the ability to
advertise on Twitter we don't have the
ability to advertise on Google at all
any plays that you see right now on
YouTube Just so you know those aren't we
can't pay we cannot pay to take our
money they will not allow us to
advertise I don't think Facebook will
either and that's not censorship that's
just you have right-of-way Elizabeth
Warren you can advertise the campaigns
that we wrote for you again do you feel
free it's not do you live in a society
with laws and it's not do you engage on
social platforms that have rules it's
are they applied equally and the answer
is invariably no if you agree with that
look hit the like button because that
pisses off YouTube with the algorithm
you can share or better yet head on over
to Rebel hit the rumble button because
that actually means something
I think I don't know what Rumble button
means I don't know what it does do you
feel better I I just know I hit the
wrong button it's cathartic
Plus
that's not a real person who is that
that's that's Tim Cook that's Tim zisu
oh yeah he was like yeah
he's definitely going like yeah we're
not gonna have Twitter on the App Store
is Elon behind me yeah bring that back
up oh yeah I was joking the Steve that's
life autistic with Tim Cesar
I feel like Denzel Washington's about to
say I just don't feel comfortable
representing you in court what do you
want Denzel I wish
you had more hats
[Music]
we're talking about okay this is a
little more General but it is something
that affects a lot of you and believe me
I hear you we'll be taking your chat on
mug Club we've all talked about this I
do think there's unfortunately a
disconnect with people who just say okay
okay Boomer like honest I can be the
people who birthed you right they've
contributed to society but I also
understand that there are some
grievances
from Generation Z from younger
Millennials who are saying that the
American dream feels further and further
Out Of Reach there is some truth to it
and by the Boomers okay older people
right now who are likely going to retire
you can't just discount this because you
are part of a generation that enjoyed
some Prosperity that won't exist before
or after just to be clear the baby boom
generation and you do need to understand
that Social Security is a Ponzi scheme
and at some point someone's going to be
screwed so when you talk to young people
who say oh I paid into Social Security
so were they they're probably not going
to get back probably not going to get it
back so I think there's a disconnect and
there is uh there's a there really is a
silver lining the beauty is yeah you
actually can live a much better life
than your parents it all comes down to
your choices and that is what you have
now that they didn't have so is the
middle class screwed uh do you have it
harder than
the Boomers and one thing I think
conservatives get wrong you can let me
know if you disagree with me here I
think sometimes the disconnect takes
place when you have conservatives saying
yeah well your parents didn't have and
they name iPhone lattes luxuries let's
not compare Necessities like home cost
or um you know how much you make at a
job or a vehicle let's not compare that
with niceties I get it a lot of young
people are irresponsible and they spend
far too much on luxuries but that's a
separate argument it's not a comparison
so it's less of being sold to them
endlessly though right is luxuries
that's what you're supposed to have you
deserve this yes right so this is
something that you'll see a lot from
like baby members will say like well why
don't you you know why haven't you
started a family why don't you have
grandchildren and I was married to your
mom and I bought a home okay this is the
kind of thing that you will hear and
then you have people who are younger
saying well that's Out Of Reach so let's
go to then and now and give you an
Apples to Apples comparison here's a
then it is a stinger oh let's go foreign
light System of a Down in anything
Casey's been waiting to hit that oh my
gosh did he just load that in he's just
waiting all right so my question to you
before I continue is do you feel like it
is Out Of Reach the American dream if
you are younger okay let me be really
clear about this I'm trying to give you
as close to an Apples to Apples
comparison as I can all of the numbers
that you hear the dollar amounts have
been adjusted for inflation so are in
today's dollars so you don't have to do
the math just to be clear because I can
hear that criticism before you make it
references are available at live
withcutter.com so let's go to then let's
look at home prices okay so uh the
adjusted again the median home price in
1963 for example was around 175 000
that's fifteen thousand then probably no
no yeah something like that yeah oh look
you cheated
good for you I cheat sometimes so
I look before the show sometimes I do a
little research I like to have a laugh
so that's then I won't lie let's look at
now okay now the median home price in
2022 is 425 000 we are in a bit of a
bubble hike but it is very expensive so
in other words that's a legitimate
grievance I understand that we'll give
some more context after let's go after
six and a half percent also right now
yeah that's very low historically that's
what people understand you know what
your parents are paying in the 70s
they're picking double digits oh yeah
that's true so a lot of that if someone
in the 60s or 70s had a six percent
they'd be like oh my God I got off easy
but that's great this generation is used
to two percent three percent again
because of artificially manipulated
markets with the Fed so let's now look
at cars that's a necessity let's go back
then original price of Chevy's most
popular truck in 63. I think it was a
C10
today's dollars about twenty thousand
dollars okay that seems pretty good now
the average full-size pickup truck is
sixty one thousand dollars that would
seem like it's far more expensive again
we're doing the same dot they're
adjusted for inflation of dollars that's
the average full-size pickup today
you had one choice back then I'll get to
that in a second
and here is one that is absolutely true
Boomers I'm just asking if you're going
to talk with your kids over the holiday
season older people you need to
understand the world they're living and
then the language that they speak let's
go back then the cost of Education okay
back then the yearly cost of tuition uh
we have a public uh public colleges
universities twenty three hundred
dollars on average private ninety seven
hundred dollars again that's in today's
dollars just to be clear geez let's go
to now and this is a real problem
tuition fees public ten thousand four
hundred dollars private forty nine
thousand dollars
wow everything was just triple until
that one right
so here's the that's incredible right
that is something where you look at it
let's add up all these costs just from
this first portion of the segment okay
see the house 425 000 car 62 000
education forty five thousand dollars
for that public four-year degree yeah
that's a public one yeah it's a public
one just to be clear you're getting off
easy
so look you can live this but does that
actually look comparable to your parents
or if you are a parent does that maybe
give you some context here as to why
young people are upset because you need
to know why they're upset so that you
can be ready for the lie that comes down
the pike and the LIE is you need the
government to come in and save you you
need the government to to provide you
know Cash for Clunkers you need the
government to provide student debt
relief right you need the government to
have rent forgiveness if you accept that
those are the same costs for everybody
or you accept the premise that you have
to go to university oh and by the way
University became unaffordable so the
government has to make up that Gap and
so if you're a university and you're not
over charging for a degree guess what
you're leaving money on the table
because some other prick who's a Dean is
going to take that Grant from Uncle Sam
let's be clear this inflation you're
living it right now more government
intervention now compare the inflation
today
versus what you had under Donald Trump
okay now
here's something by the time our kids
are old enough though so I interrupt
you're going to have to be a millionaire
to survive well you would that's what
you would believe until you take some
other things into consideration if
you're doing Apples to Apples this was
the path for my parents right what you
would do is you would go to college then
you'd work a job and then you would
retire you'd be able to get vacation
you'd live in this house you'd have this
car there are a lot die with regret yes
that some things remain steadfast okay
good but there are a lot of variables
that aren't being taken into
consideration young people so that first
portion was for older people parents and
how to talk with your kids understanding
where they're coming from go check out
the references young people let me
provide you with some hope here and this
isn't false hope so let's look at sure
homes seem expensive but let's look at
what happened to homes over the last
half a century the size of the average
American Home has grown by more than a
thousand square feet
okay there were no man caves and there
certainly were no reality shows about
your home bar it didn't exist you're
talking about a thousand to 1500 square
feet okay now let's look at cars right
well you can get by the way an economy
car for around that 20 something
thousand dollars only keep in mind that
the economy car today actually does have
air conditioning which that truck did
not have back then actually last two a
hundred thousand miles which was the Max
on the odometer back then has airbags
seat belts the point is you have options
if you're saying truck to truck sure
what about truck to crossover SUV what
about truck to economy car if you're
saying house to house sure what about
1300 square foot house to 1300 square
foot house we need to do the Apples to
Apples comparison if we're going to do
dollars with the size and with the
amenities with the capabilities that
come with it again no air can how many
people out there
who are poor who live in Texas or
Florida driving a car today without air
conditioning no no and but just don't
skip over this power steering you don't
have to be liver King to actually turn a
car now right if you've ever driven a
car without power steering we had bigger
forearms back then for a reason yeah it
was pretty much impossible to turn yeah
just and also even shifting back then it
was kind of task you never couldn't do
it he's on so many stories his ligaments
are a fine powder oh I gotta turn
I assure you that car from the 60s isn't
automatic no
you were much busier yeah and the clutch
actively hated you right
so we have all these safety standards
now we're talking about cars fatalities
have dropped 78 since 1960. and again
they last two to three times as long you
have this from The New York Times all
the references are publicly available
okay here's something else let's look at
the houses okay you buy a home right now
for the same price and the same square
footage as the average house in 1963.
you can you can buy a home today at
around that same price
so a rural home in uh Fates Texas for
example 199 000 even an urban condo in
North Dallas 169 thousand dollars that's
a smaller one just comes with a
bulletproof vest yes it does yes well
it's like bullet for three of these yeah
they tell you to Bob and week they just
ask you to walk around with the glass so
it becomes the best you're going to want
the garage and shut it quickly after you
pull in yes and keep the exhaust running
because it's going to be a rough night
no reason to stay alive there
so it's giving Apples to Apples
comparison for that exact same car you
spend twenty thousand dollars that your
parents spend you can have a very
reliable car with amenities that they
didn't have for example you can get a
2018-2019 Ford Fusion you can get a 2018
to 2020 Toyota Camry you can get a
Subaru Legacy but why would you come on
no like we have lesbians
doesn't who he tries hey you can get
cars for ten thousand dollars 2014
Chevrolet Spark seventy seven hundred
dollars a Kia Soul don't talk about
those gerbil commercials I swear to God
I will murder you ninety five hundred
dollars Nissan Versa which I will never
drive ever again
now so yeah I rented one of those and I
was like could I get something I won't
die in if something if wind or is it a
Nissan Versa Versa oh yeah I had that
too was it LAX yeah it was yeah they
always have the Nissan Versa that's the
one time I got it the last time I got a
ticket was LAX a Nissan sorry this is an
aside but this really matters yes
don't don't rent one door buy one no
when you're in La people who live in
urban areas you don't know if your
headlights are on or off because
everything is lit right you're driving
in an urban area here's the problem with
this year of Nissan Versa I leave Hertz
at LAX the headlights aren't on I
couldn't know because all the interior
lights automatically turned on as though
it was nighttime so I get pulled over by
a police officer not a mile from LAX
saying uh hey you know why you pulled
you over and I wasn't even a smartass I
said like I
know you hear this a lot I genuinely
have no idea he goes uh so you don't see
a need for headlights
lights
I'm missing no the lights are on exactly
the headlights are on I said you're
bullshitting
he said tell it to a judge oh and I did
and I lost and then four other La cops
came and beat the [ __ ] out of you no no
that was resisting sir that was the
citizens when I was doing my weekly semi
route oh right I dragged enough
so we have homes hey you can do it your
parents did cars hey you can do it your
parents you can even do it for cheaper
and have more luxuries let's look at
education we have we have a quick
breaking news story okay oh what's
happening guys
yeah
yeah
[Music]
it's better yeah you know why they're on
the street because it won't start
because it's a piece of crap
by the way could it be more racist
that's very true
yeah you know they're hamsters doing
black stuff that's my [ __ ] yeah yeah
flavor cage
hey what are you talking about I don't
know they're just happy to be out of
Richard Gere and singing again
it created by a bunch of Koreans yeah
animal like a black man
yeah it's good Richard prayer fine who's
gonna watch that commercial go yeah yeah
that's my kind of that's that's the kind
of car Gerald did at one point he likes
them I know I did that not I used to own
one listen we used to own the car but
you didn't like the commercials were
shipped
with your giant gold cross and
Timberlands
they just here's the thing don't trust
experts
expert Ad Agency came up with that and
no one stopped it for example I had a
fridge that broke and so I got a new
fridge I swear to you and I'm gonna get
to education in a second but I swear to
you this is a fridge
and when I was a kid I used to think
that if you had an ice maker or water
from your fridge you were the rich
person yeah
well I can't be busy being bothered with
what am I retired so usually you have
left and right ice right you have ice
and you have water or you have a button
with one spout that goes from Ice to
water the engineers decided that in this
one they were going to have the ice
button recessed into the fridge and then
the water button in front of it here's
the problem
in the middle of the night there's only
one light so if I put my cup up to get
water I'm covering the only light for
the ice spout and it leaks all over the
floor and now I have water damage no one
at Maytag said hey hold on a second
he won't see the light these are the
experts your engineers didn't realize
the problem that took me three seconds I
think it's important to say this one too
if you can even find it the 2003 Focus
was a Detroit techno Fest Focus oh boy
this was a car designed for people on a
designer drug yes like it was for people
on ecstasy listening to techno music and
even at a commercial for it and I was
like is ecstasy so popular that we're
actually just making it into cars right
like somebody's like yes it is a
pacifier just at Ford like I got an idea
yes more speakers in this tiny car why
do you think the name the next one the
fiesta yeah there you go we're gonna
feature the movie go is it safer no no
not especially with one of us behind the
wheel yes wait till you see our Ford
burning man yeah
[Applause]
the Subaru Coachella firefest
they're just all piled up it's just a
bunch of lesbians on an island so no I'm
telling you how insane is this this is
why nobody really this is the focus this
was Tony it was designed it was a it's a
drug add four people on ecstasy you
would have to be on drugs to think that
car looks good yeah it's so plain this
is for somebody rolling on E look at
that
the editors are gonna have their work
cut out for Crowder bits so
we've gone through housing we've gone
through edu we've gone through cars now
let's get to education this is one
this is one that is a problem if you
believe that you have to get a college
education today hint that's a lie so we
compared the cost right it's more than
four times when you're talking about a a
major university or or so now you have
the home price it's the same as your
parents now you have a car that's
cheaper than your parents you have more
luxuries you have air conditioning hey
seat belts you're doing better but let's
compare University versus a trade school
cost on average for trade school is
somewhere around five thousand dollars
to complete and if you look at people
who graduate from trade school unlike
people who have a master's in gender
studies starting salaries depending on
the trade they can they can begin at
eighty thousand dollars so let's go
through this in a conclusion sure are
houses more expensive in general yes are
cars more expensive in general sure if
you want to get the expensive car is
college tuition more expensive in
general absolutely ask astronomically so
but that doesn't have to be the American
dream because you can now live in a more
rural area or suburban area or you can
live in a condo which was not an option
available to people in the 1960s you can
pay the same amount as your parents have
modern amenities you know like air
conditioning locks you can drive a car a
used car an economy car for cheaper than
your parents you can go to trade school
and make more money than your parents
could have ever dreamed of making in
their early 20s that is an option that
is available to you right now you just
have to go out and take it and not think
that for example a Ford Focus or a
Subaru Outback or for example being an
electrician is beneath you because
that's what you're missing your parents
didn't think that it was beneath them
yeah they made this and they got to go
on vacation your dad was working on a
factory line just to be clear
you want to work in an office and by the
way you don't think that you should have
to go into the office because you were
raised during a pandemic that was well I
shouldn't say you were raising it you
were raised during government policies
thrust upon you under the guise of a
pandemic where you think you can show up
to work maybe twice a month and make
that kind of a full-time salary you have
far more Choice available to you that's
why the left is so aggressive and
pushing the LIE they need you to believe
the lie so that you are dependent upon
them to sustain your life because hey if
you believe school is out of reach a car
is Out Of Reach A House Is Out Of Reach
every government policy will be accepted
with open arms when you understand the
options that you have guess what
congratulations you've now just turned
into a registered Republican or at the
very least a conservative you don't need
an R next to your name so you can
comment below I'd like to hear your
choices that you have made if you're a
millennial if you're Generation Z I
really wanted to recap this because we
hear look this is the one sort of
showing the right where a lot of you the
average viewers I think 28 years old 31
years old they were not selling we don't
I mean we have Gordon Lydia waiting in
the wings he's on retainer we haven't
used him yet right right of course I
mean not yet yeah but you are right I
mean that's very interesting about that
well I I would have said it was dead but
now that I think about it it's not well
it's just like right here we it's like
okay go 20 miles go 20 miles out and now
the house prices crap and you're right
you're working on the line you know yeah
and I mean you're drunk here cigarette
hanging out of your mouth sure you still
come home with all your fingers and a
paycheck that's amazing that's exactly
that's a win yeah well and they want it
now that's one of the biggest problems
is that kids right now see the success
of their parents and they go oh I want
all of that right now whereas their
parents were at least maybe not this
previous generation gen Z but the baby
members were like I'm gonna work for it
and get it over time I'm gonna make
smart decisions throughout some of them
a lot of them are entitled not all of
them a lot of them are entitled to
people who vote Republican because they
go I got my pension I got my I got my
Social Security they became entitled in
my opinion A lot of them they they went
to work they went and fought the great
Wars they went and did everything that
they were supposed to do and then said
we are entitled to this in the
entitlement carried over to the Next
Generation the 70s kids and they said oh
we are entitled to this the government
we're that's Baby Boomers you're talking
about the great generation is when we
fought World War II well baby boomers
came after maybe World War II and then
the Korean War and you know yeah yeah
but that wasn't the Great War the Great
War you're a little off on your timeline
but the principle remains some of them
are good some of them are Pricks that's
true and you don't get everything right
now you have to work for it a little bit
yeah it takes time and you do have
choices available to you and this is
really what it comes when we're talking
about Twitter we're talking about big
Tech it really does come down to one
side and look woo right left man they
want to have you keep fighting with each
other no no that's a stupid thing that
fence sitters use as an excuse to be a
[ __ ] hey man let's stop fighting hold
on a second we just had we just got into
three fights today why because Elizabeth
Warren wants entire government control
of big Tech
I am willing to fight that's not someone
who engineered me man to fight no that's
wrong I want to fight her why because I
don't like her and I don't like her
ideas figuratively to be clear she's far
too brittle
she went down steroids same thing we're
talking about Mark Zuckerberg we're
talking about student loan forgiveness
we're talking about rent forgiveness
what does that really mean is it means
it screws the person
who is not a landlord who is a home
provider who has to make those payments
if you keep buying into the LIE think of
this for a second
we've talked about wealth transfers okay
with uh covet uh private wealth
transfers to the tune of hundreds of
billions of dollars when you're talking
about you know Amazon and apple during
the pandemic because Mom and Pop shops
were close what kind of a wealth
transfer do you think happens if you buy
into all these lies and you say yeah no
I don't even go to trade school and uh
you know work a job myself what I need
is student loan forgiveness the
government just to the tune of hundreds
of billions of dollars just says hey
we're now going to give this to
universities hey now they're wealthier
you say oh you know hold on a second
wait a second uh you know I don't have
the money for a car hey you know what we
get we're gonna we're gonna provide some
kind of a grant guess what now you have
auto manufacturers who have also
received bailouts they're much richer
yeah the wealth that would be in the
middle class if you made your own
choices is now in their pockets what do
you think happens with I can't afford a
home well you know what hold on a second
we're going to make sure that banks for
they're forced to lend to you then we'll
call it predatory lending they will lend
to you despite the fact that you cannot
make those payments back we will make up
the difference now you have banks that
are too big to fail it is a giant wealth
transfer the problem is when you see
socialists and people like Bernie
Sanders saying it's a wealth transfer
from the one percent as though it's
taking place because of a voluntary
exchange of goods and services now the
wealth transfer that is taking place is
always by force from locking you down
and shutting down your business but
keeping Costco and Walmart and Amazon
open to saying hey you know what
independent people independent landlords
home providers we're going to keep you
on the hook and everyone else who's a
non-contributing zero we're gonna make
sure you don't have to pay rent two kids
who want to waste time with four years
of glorified alcoholism saying hey you
know what we're actually going to take
from the pockets of the people who went
to trade school and are paying taxes and
make sure that you pay for the student
loan forgiveness for this person who
won't be able to find a job anyway the
wealth transfers aren't just taking
they're not taking place from the
capitalist system and they're taking
place before your very eyes and they're
presented to you as a gift has the gift
made home prices better has the gift
made College more affordable
you have to ask yourself that and then
gratefully look at the options before
you and yes make better choices despite
the fact that it's a more complicated
world all right we're going to chat
Thursday we will see you in New Jersey
and Baltimore this weekend we're going
to talk about the U.S women's oh my god
let's go piss off YouTube
[Music]